[Musique]
le nectar de ces petites fleurs blanches
attirent les abeilles c'est peut-être ce
qui lui vaut son surnom d'herbe à miel
mais on l'appelle aussi aird hammouche
véronique macau âmes
dans les jardins créoles ses feuilles
poilus marque et de nervures franche ne
trompent pas ibtissem rubens de mesure
et de 1 3 m de long
c'est une plante que l'on trouve dans
tout le bassin caribéen mais aussi en
amérique tropicale et en afrique
depuis des siècles les populations
locales savent reconnaître les
propriétés de l'herbe à mouches
[Musique]
ses effets en cas de fièvre de
rhumatismes ou de problèmes
respiratoires lorsqu'elle est consommée
en décoction et surtout ses miracles
contre toutes sortes d'infections
cutanées ponctuelle à l'instar de
champignons d'irritation de
démangeaisons pour plus chroniques comme
les eczémas
aujourd'hui les analyses scientifiques
permettent de connaître le détail de sa
composition on sait par exemple qu'elle
contient les alcaloïdes molécules
présentes dans de nombreuses plantes
mais dont le rôle est encore une énigme
plusieurs des plantes qui en contiennent
sont boudés par les animaux en raison de
leur amertume
c'est sans doute ce qui alimente aussi
les qualités anti microbienne de l'herbe
à mouches une propriété qui a mis en
évidence le projet à mme bale du pôle
agro ressources et de recherche de
martinique au niveau de l'activité
antimicrobienne on a pu mettre en
évidence une forte inhibition de la
prolifération de certains germes on a
montré cette forte activité sur
l'escherichia coli staphylococcus aureus
qui sont deux germes responsables de
toxi infection donc là on est vraiment
sur des applications possibles en termes
de développement de produits d'hygiène
ou ce qu'on appelle produits d'hygiène
ce sont des produits de désinfection
alors on pourrait viser les produits
pour la désinfection du matériel des
équipements des locaux qui permettrait
de bien maîtriser l'environnement et
éviter le développement de ces germes
ont ces temps où tout doit être
désinfectée il se pourrait donc on
compte bientôt sur l'huile essentielle
de l'iti saint trop' rubens pour
nettoyer nos bureaux et ce pourrait être
agréable car cette plante dégage une
odeur délicate et sur laquelle des tests
ont déjà été réalisés notamment à grasse
capitale mondiale de la parfumerie les
différends nés qui se sont penchés sur
elle et ont reconnu des notes
aromatiques frites et bien sûr si en
plus de la sentir vous choisissez de la
consommer il faut être prudent si des
plantes peut soigner demandez conseil à
votre médecin
[Musique]
bon